al verlas se pone un poco enojado frunce
el ceño y está a punto de explotar
porque tú y un pájaro lo han dejado en
ridículo en frente del rey entonces
decide salir de la habitación bien
enojado se tranquilizó un poco y después
entra de nuevo a la habitación de dice o
es muy cierto fue mi culpa pobre de mí
que estoy viejito en la primera semana
nosotros compramos dos kilogramos de
manzanas y un kilogramo de plátanos pero
no pagamos tres pesos pagamos en esta
ocasión cinco pesos perdonen perdonen mi
error mi falta de concentración sin
embargo el trae un plan detrás para que
tú y el pájaro sean los que van a quedar
en ridículo y no estén más en el reino
así que te dicen a ver si son tan
inteligentes como pueden resolver este
problema y bueno pues entonces vamos a
tratar de utilizar las mismas variables
que en el vídeo pasado para resolver de
nuevo este problema así que tenemos que
es igual al precio que vamos a obtener
de las manzanas por kilogramo mientras
que penn
el precio que vamos a tener de los
plátanos por kilogramo y por lo tanto la
primera ecuación me va a quedar de nuevo
2a más b iguala y en esta ocasión vamos
a cambiar recuerden que el consejero
cometió un grave error y dijo que eran 3
pero ahora son 5 entonces el nuevo
precio o el nuevo número que vamos a
poner aquí es 5 mientras que en mi otra
ecuación sigue intacta 6 a más 3 b es
igual a 15 6 kilogramos de manzanas más
3 kilogramos de plátanos son igual a 15
pesos pagamos por estos 215 pesos y es
suma porque nos llevamos las dos frutas
por lo tanto ya tengo mi segunda
ecuación y esta segunda ecuación no ha
cambiado hasta ahorita 6 a más 3 b es
igual a 15 y entonces dice es bueno yo
sé bastante de encontrar soluciones de
ecuaciones ya mí me gusta mucho el
método de suma y resta o el método de
eliminación es el mismo por lo tanto lo
que voy a hacer es tomarme la primera
ecuación y la voy a multiplicar otra vez
por menos 3 de tal manera que voy a
cancelar
los términos correspondientes para ver
qué es lo que me queda lo multiplicó por
menos 3 porque la idea en ciales
cancelarla
y 2a por menos 3 me va a quedar menos 6
a lo cual se va a poder cancelar después
me queda p por menos 3 que es menos 3 b
y 5 x menos 3 lo cual me da menos 15 y
aquí es cuando dices creo que también
hay algo raro por aquí porque 6 a menos
6 am se van
3b - 3 b también se van y 15 menos 15
también se van vamos a cancelarlo se va
se va de este lado me queda 0 y aquí me
queda 15 menos 15 lo cual también me
queda 0 y dices oh no no estoy
encontrando otra vez valores de a ni
debe esta versión de un poquito más
lógico porque me quedo que 0 es igual a
0 lo cual es cierto pero no tengo ningún
valor de ningún valor de b por lo tanto
volteas a ver al pájaro ya sabes que el
pájaro tiene bastante de sentido común
hasta ahorita te guiado bastante bien y
el pájaro le susurra al rey y el rey te
dice gráfica gráfica
vamos a graficar otra vez vamos a ver
qué es lo que nos sale si hacemos las
gráficas de estas dos funciones por lo
tanto déjame tomar de nuevo el color
blanco y vamos a dibujar nuestros dos
ejes para que obtengamos nuestro plano
cartesiano y vamos a ver qué es lo que
pasa este va a ser el eje de las veces
después tenemos el eje de las as y voy a
hacer lo mismo que hice en el vídeo
pasado voy a despejar a ver para que yo
pueda graficar entonces aquí tengo los
valores que puede tomar ven y am y de la
primera ecuación que me va a quedar me
queda que ven es igual a 2 y lo voy a
pasar del otro lado restando y el 5 se
queda igual entonces me queda que ven es
igual a menos 2 a más 5 2 a para ser el
otro lado con signo contrario y después
esta es miren al origen esto quiere
decir que corta el eje de las veces en 5
positivo y ahora me voy a fijar en la
pendiente la cual vale menos 2 esto
quiere decir que voy a bajar 2 mb y
moverme uno hacia la derecha para
encontrar mi otro punto podemos si
queremos encontrar otro punto bajando 2
m y moviéndose 1
y ya con estos puntos tengo la gráfica
de la recta que me da b es igual a menos
25 y aquí tengo la gráfica de esta recta
así que vamos a trabajar con la segunda
ecuación a ver cuál es su gráfica y para
que veamos también qué es lo que está
pasando entonces dejen escribirla por
aquí me queda que 3 b es igual a menos 6
a más 15 pase del otro lado el 6 por lo
tanto el de cambio de signo y después
voy a dividir todo entre 3 no va a
quedar esto entre 3 esto entre 3 es
entre 3 y me queda que ven es igual a
menos 2 a más 5 también si se dan
cuentas la misma ecuación entonces va a
cortar en el eje de las veces en el
valor de 5 positivo y después va a tener
una pendiente también de menos 2 por lo
tanto va a ser la misma recta estoy
graficando de nuevo la misma recta
porque tiene la misma pendiente y tiene
la misma ordenada al origen y por lo
tanto estamos hablando de la misma recta
ya que es cuando decimos a la regla otra
vez no está tomando el pelo porque
tenemos una infinidad de soluciones para
qué
apuntó que está en esta recta está
también en la otra recta pues estamos
hablando de que son la misma recta y
entonces nosotros volteamos a ver al
pájaro a ver qué se le ocurre ahora y lo
que se le ocurre el pájaro bueno al
menos eso es lo que dice el rey es que
compramos plátanos y compramos manzanas
a la misma razón al final si te das
cuenta tenemos esta misma ecuación
solamente que multiplicada por 3
multiplicamos 3 veces la cantidad de
kilogramos de manzanas que compramos
tres veces la cantidad de kilogramos de
plátanos que compramos y por lo tanto va
a costar tres veces más pues triplicamos
exactamente la compra y bueno es que al
final estamos diciendo lo mismo
solamente que estamos multiplicando todo
por 3
entonces volteamos a ver a la regla y
realmente al verla no nos está mintiendo
del todo lo único que está pasando es
que no está diciendo dos veces lo mismo
una vez normal y la otra vez
multiplicada por tres es decir nos está
dando una información insuficiente y
esto nos lleva a que entonces nuestro
sistema sea consistente date cuenta 0 es
igual a 0 pero tenemos una
unidad de soluciones por lo tanto se
dice que las ecuaciones son dependientes
dependientes porque son la misma
ecuación y si son la misma ecuación
entonces para cualquier punto de esta
recta se cumple lo que quiere decir que
tenemos una infinidad de soluciones y
bueno entonces volteamos a ver al verla
y le decimos si realmente quieres que
resolvamos este problema nos vas a tener
que dar una información correcta y no
solamente la misma razón de compra de
plátanos y de manzanas